hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday September 16th 2019 what's
going on how why yeah how's it going oh
is it really having a tough one already
well you have [ __ ] because it's Monday
buddy or lady or damn days whoever's
listening
how are you how'd you how great was the
[ __ ] weekend huh football like the
first week it's like he came believe
that football's back and then you like
who's good who isn't who the [ __ ] is
this guy
that guy still in the league you know
when once that all takes a week and then
the second week he like oh that's right
I didn't dream last week this is real
man it's all he did was watch football I
watched a college I watched the pros
it's all I did I had such a [ __ ]
great time I did some other [ __ ] too I
can remember during the day but uh
Saturday night I went to I saw Iron
Maiden at the new soccer stadium that
they they they tore down the LA Sports
Coliseum and I don't know I guess I
don't watch the news I had no idea that
they were tearing that down iconic venue
it's where the Lakers first played you
know Wilt Chamberlain and who's the
white dude who's too [ __ ] this symbol
of the NBA was it Rick Barry I forget
anyway the place of Bob koozies last
game beat the Lakers in the finals as
they always used to back in the day
so anyways they knocked that [ __ ] down
and they put up this gorgeous new soccer
stadium that I would say rivals anything
that's out there in the Premier League
you know it is England tries and then
America does it better and then they
make fun of how fat we are I mean that's
basically what it is but at the end of
the day okay England you had a great run
but we're gonna take over soccer now
second we decide we have all the best
players on this side of the globe you
know it's true you know it's true
they're all on this side of the globe
they're not in this country they're all
the way down south and if we look at the
globe it's kind of halfway would be
halfway to Europe it's halfway to half
or all down to you know Central America
South America I'm just [ __ ] with you I
don't know [ __ ] about soccer but the
stadium was beautiful although nobody
could [ __ ] nobody knew where to go I
went I saw I saw Iron Maiden on the
legacy of the Beast tour where they were
coming out 40 years of the band and they
were playing all the hits and they did
and I don't think the band has ever
sounded better
they absolutely [ __ ] blew me away
Bruce Dickinson voice was incredible
Nicko McBrain used to see the guy's drum
kit I actually want to post a video of
it because you know it has all that like
his drum kit so works of art I don't
know who paints those things who comes
up with the concept but his drum kit
it's red but it looks like it's made out
of stained glass when it's underneath
the lights including the drum had the
front bass drum and is also a
stained-glass kind of thing and I went
on YouTube and I was watching because I
was like I got to see this video up
close because they kind of had him
behind like this fence for a little bit
before the fence came down or whatever
and all his [ __ ] you know all the
theatrics and each one of his toms this
guy did like a different like motif of
all the different Eddie's throughout the
years all the different album covers and
despite all the albums that they have he
seems to have just as many drum Tom's
going around his kit and yeah I just
cannot say enough I'll [ __ ] great the
band sounded and Jesus Christ Dave
Murray my god is that guy a beast I
always don't him I hate he was spent a
little [ __ ] amazing but just that
[ __ ] he sounded like the record you
know he just starts playing he never
even looks at the guitar he just kind of
puts his head back
and I went with Dean Delray which made
it even better and right out of the gate
Bruce Dickinson made a joke about how
old they all were while trash in America
in a funny way where he's like we know
the other day we did a hole like it
through the back said he did we added up
all our ages and we're actually older
than this country and don't you forget
it we are you have [ __ ] grandfathers
your granddaddy's is something like that
I was a really funny joke crowd [ __ ]
laughed killed killed with the joke and
then proceeded to absolutely destroy and
I don't know it just really took me back
because believe it or not as much as I
talk about John Bonham Nicko McBrain was
the reason why I started playing drums
because I watched that live after death
VHS tape a million times when they were
down in Long Beach and I was you know
blown away by the band but at one point
they actually had a shot that you never
saw back in the day they never had it
was basically shooting behind the
drummer and you could see all four limbs
doing something different yet all
working together and I just remembered
that just you know guitar just seemed
like impossible to me I didn't have the
year but drums that look more like
physical and I was playing sports I was
just like that's the coolest [ __ ]
thing I think I've ever seen and that's
what really and that thing came out like
86 and by 88 I had a kit and I was
playing and then on the other side this
is how much this band means to me is
Bruce Dickinson is like a sickle it was
such a unbelievable pilot that he
actually flies the goddamn 747 or
whatever they have he flies the damp
band and the whole crew around he's got
you know it's him and the copilot and I
don't know I kind of got a kick out of
that last night going look at Bruce
tickets and the guy's a total [ __ ]
rock star he's got to keep this the you
know the plates spinning here to keep
people coming to the show just dripping
sweat and all that [ __ ] but he still had
time to go out and get his instrument
rating I can do this
I don't have nearly the tour schedule
this guy and he somehow figured out how
to do it so I've been tearing through
the chapters in the prep test and then I
bought this awesome book that just
really goes into detail and I cannot
[ __ ] believe how much into whether
and how the instrument works and
everything I just I kind of took the
pressure off where it's like if I don't
take the written test or the the
multiple-choice test by the end of the
year there's a whole new test next-gen
you know something so I was under the
gun and I'm trying to go through the
book so I'm just like you know what I
don't give a [ __ ] so what then I might
have to [ __ ] reread some other [ __ ]
and I'll know what twice is good next
year I don't care I just want to instead
of having the pressure of trying to I
got to take this test which I still
think I'm going to by the end of the
year I want to get and stay locked into
the fun of learning all of this stuff
and how fascinating it is and how human
beings figured out how to [ __ ] do
this you know many of them costing them
their lives so everybody can be safe up
there like I swear to god the more you
get into aviation test pilots are out of
their [ __ ] minds out of their [ __ ]
minds the [ __ ] that they do to make sure
to find the limits you know push it
right up to the brink and then they come
back like yeah you know you probably
shouldn't do that I would love to talk
to a test pilot someday on this podcast
and just listen to the [ __ ] stories
as my blood turns [ __ ] cold and I
just want to be like you know do you
just would you wake up in the middle of
the night and cold sweats you know
anytime I've had one of those dreams
it's a hypothetical they actually
[ __ ] livid so it's really incredible
so anyway we go to the concert it's at
the new whatever the [ __ ] Bank of
whatever Coliseum and rent it up I had a
buddy you know I got the drummer from
Instagram who hooked us up and me and
Dean up and we got to you know go into
like the VIP area but then what was
awesome was we didn't have like douchey
VIP seats we would like stood the whole
concert we were down on the floor there
was like a [ __ ] mosh pit broke out of
only a couple of times but
just the whole face then you would down
there on the field and you got to look
up and see how many people this band
still draws by the way they have [ __ ]
merch lines I thought it was the line to
get into the concert and it was just
people standing there to buy their
t-shirts and somebody told me that iron
made to set the record for set the
record for the most merged ever sold at
a concert I think it was in Australia
they sold $750,000 in [ __ ] t-shirts
[Laughter]
[Music]
unreal unfuckin real so you know Steve
Harris is always Emma be used to win
like best rock bassist every single year
you know him and Cliff Burton were the
two [ __ ] coolest guys I thought as
far as in the 80s the guys coming up you
know they played with the fingers they
didn't have the pick or whatever which I
know you know the pic gives you a
different sound and has merits but I
always just thought the guys would play
with the fingers just always look the
[ __ ] coolest and I heard through the
grapevine that he was actually feeling
under the weather and you never would
have known you know total [ __ ] Pro
just went up there and absolutely killed
it and such a I cannot say enough about
the show absolutely blew me away and I
would go see it again in a second I went
up to their merch table at the end and
everything was like sold out I wasn't
trying to get something from me I was
trying to get something for my daughter
I wanted to get her like a a cool little
shirt or whatever but what's cool is
they make like like one-off shirts just
for that venue like I'm sure the Vegas
one was cool probably had something to
do with gambling but this one actually
had EDT like diving to save a ball and a
goalie net it was actually really cool
by the time I got up there they were out
of my size so but I went to what the 1/8
[ __ ] he got it too but then the people
watching there was hilarious it was
[ __ ] everybody it was like people
older than me if you can believe it a
lot of people my age and you just get to
talk to people when you first see him
and all that stuff I missed him in the
80s unfortunately I just did so bad in
school my parents will watch me like a
hawk so I got to see priests but I never
got to see Maiden and first time I saw
him was 2006 and I was so psyched
another thing too was I watched that
that live after death think so for so
[ __ ] long that it became a
catchphrase between me and all my
siblings of Bruce Dickinson going scream
for me Long Beach scrape from a log page
we would just do any time we would bring
up hey Iron Maiden has a new album
coming out and then some some more in a
verbal yell scream for me Long Beach and
when we saw him Saturday night Bruce
Dickinson was going scream for me Los
Angeles the iconic thing that he said
and me and Dean just looked at each
other like oh my god he's saying the
thing that we watched that fanboy thing
it was [ __ ] awesome you know what
else was great not drinking and being
stoned [ __ ] sober remembering the
whole goddamn concert and Jesus Christ
there was some [ __ ] people getting
after it god bless him I did it for
years this guy walked by me and I
couldn't get out of the way because you
know we're drunk person walks it's like
watching a bat fly you don't know what
the [ __ ] they're doing and he ended up
[ __ ] bumping into me and I swear to
God I felt I was playing pick-up hoop
you know when everybody else is playing
and then you sub in and you haven't been
playing and you're like bone dry and
that guy post up against you and you're
like all his [ __ ] slime yeah that was
the only down part of the [ __ ] show
other than that was awesome all right
there you go enough of that so I watched
yes I'm coming up on 300 days no booze I
feel great but I'm not gonna lie to you
I still miss it I keep talking to people
that quit forever and they're just like
yeah dude I don't mean I don't even miss
it anymore
I just think I need more experiences
like that but I'm not gonna [ __ ] lie
to you dude I'm not gonna lie to you a
[ __ ] ice-cold Miller High Life right
now with a little shorty next to it
sounds pretty [ __ ] awesome so it's
pretty [ __ ] awesome so I don't know
yeah can you can you feel me fighting it
I've got 300 days on Friday and my you
know I got to break the record so I know
my personal record so I know I'm gonna
go at least
367 days and I also know I want to go to
count of the year so I know I'm gonna at
least make it to the [ __ ] Rose Bowl
but then next year is going to be tough
because that's when you know I got the
record my own I beat my own personal
bests and then it's just gonna be like
how long am I gonna [ __ ] take this
for you know what am i doing will you do
next bill never have ice cream again
yeah there's been a couple of tide on or
whatever I don't put I don't know maybe
I'll go back maybe I won't I don't know
I have no idea this is like one of the
end of us are [ __ ] you know Dallas
like who shot jr. like is Bill gonna
start boozing again I do think it's
funny that you guys can't say it Billy
booze face anymore Billy booze bag and
under that [ __ ] yeah now what are you
gonna do just attack me for my looks my
all-natural sober looks you sons of
[ __ ] by the way thank you guys for
all the emails you sent it's been an
overwhelming response to my latest
special and I couldn't be [ __ ]
happier I think it really I think I
really kind of pushed through to another
level on this one as far as like people
their responses to it you know there's
always going to be a couple of boo birds
out there but that is kind of the way
it's always been
it's just how it always is you know it's
funny couple people when like ah why you
really went hard on this topic or that
topic and I would you interviews the son
would be like you know actually I didn't
if you watch my other specials there's
there's no difference in tone I'm hoping
I got better as a comic but as far as
what I've been talking about going at
[ __ ] it's just been the same you know
there's no reason to hit a woman there's
plenty of reasons you just don't do it
I've been doing jokes like that right
along its just this last weird four
years where all of these spoiled brats
started acting like they cared you know
and so much of their caring really has
to do just about themselves so everyone
can look at like what a great [ __ ]
person they are while and they just
totally bully everybody else who doesn't
think the way they think and they
try to ruin their careers and that's
gonna be their legacy and I'm telling
you I really feel like it's coming to an
end and you watch all of them scurry
away like a bunch of [ __ ] rats I'm
telling you just like during that
McCarthyism and one [ __ ] person took
the blame Senator Joe McCarthy but there
was a bunch of other people that went
around ratting out their [ __ ] friends
and all of this [ __ ] are not [ __ ]
sticking up for people who are falsely
accused it really is sort of the liberal
McCarthyism that I just feel like it's
gonna come to it you can only keep
people inside on sunny days for so
[ __ ] long before they were before
they want to [ __ ] come back outside
again all right haven't said that I'm
not saying to be a [ __ ] [ __ ] to
anybody but like the goddamn word police
[ __ ] ridiculous and I'm having a
great time making fun of white women too
who really should glance over their
shoulder every once in a while out there
[ __ ] Lexus SUV [ __ ] window you
know before they start pointing fingers
at [ __ ] privileged people it's really
just it's just like I just jaw on the
[ __ ] ground you know I watch this
[ __ ] thing the other day and it was
this great thing on like Joan Rivers and
The Tonight Show and all that and you
know Johnny groomed her and all this
stuff as far as broader in and all that
however you want to say whatever the
[ __ ] those guys do you know the all
those guys that he lied and let him and
let on all that and when she did she
ended up getting a talk show that
competed against his own [ __ ] show
didn't let him know and he found out you
know the way every just regular jerk-off
found out and then he never talked to
her again and I saw I don't know if I
already talked abouts just blew me away
somebody goes like you know and if a guy
did that it wouldn't have been a problem
it's like it abso-fucking-lutely would
have been a problem it adds to [ __ ]
lutely would have been a problem but
that is like this [ __ ] dialogue that
has just been out there it's just like a
woman has a bad day and if a guy did the
exact same thing 100% of the [ __ ]
time it's all [ __ ] sunshine it's just
like alright alright you're done making
you I thought I was the only one making
a [ __ ] cartoon out there
Jesus Christ of the Miami Dolphins stink
my god you know what it is you guys have
such wonderful weather down there other
than those [ __ ] you know end of the
world hurricanes there has to be a
balance that's the only thing that
explains it
I actually didn't see any of the [ __ ]
game because I they got this new fight
they used to what the DirecTV if you
order the football package you
automatically renewed again the next
year I don't know what the [ __ ] is going
on at DIRECTV
it doesn't renew you got to call them up
I don't know I don't know how to [ __ ]
you subscribe but now it's only like 60
9.99 it used to be a hundred something
because now everybody's [ __ ]
streaming the [ __ ] and then they got the
Apple TV and then they project it up on
the thing I would have [ __ ] you do that
turn your laptop into a projector huh is
it on the Wi-Fi [ __ ] [ __ ] and it goes
through your friends head and into your
TV
and then you're slowly giving your
friend brain cancer as you watch the
Lions first to San Diego Chargers which
was one one of the ugliest two quarters
of football that I've ever [ __ ] seen
it's like I felt like both of them had
to deal with the mob and they were
supposed to lose every time they would
get they make a good play that was a
penalty any time they scored they [ __ ]
up they missing field gold I mean it was
[ __ ] ugly it was as ugly as the
beauty of the Kansas City Chiefs second
quarter against the Raiders that just
[ __ ] nuke to that entire stadium
believe it or not the Raiders were
actually winning that game seven or
nothing and Patrick mahomes is just
[ __ ] scary how good that guy is how
[ __ ] good that guy is and how young
he is in his career and I'm making fun
of that time when he had that first good
game on a national as far as like Monday
Night Football and that guy was just
like Patrick you know I was like Jesus
[ __ ] Christ relax the guy had a good
game you know you're already putting him
in the fleet putting him in Canton Ohio
but I got to tell you that guy was right
that guy was right and I was wrong
you know and I'm I'm big enough of a man
to admit that I've really learned over
the years being married how to say I'm
wrong when I'm wrong
dude that guy threw four touchdown
passes in the second quarter now listen
I didn't see the game I just watched the
highlights there was some really suspect
coverage on a couple of those things but
two of them were really difficult the
last one was a beautiful back shoulder
throw I don't know
as much as people around the Patriots
dick we played the Steelers who are
still trying to put it together and then
we played the Dolphins and they stink
and I don't know Kansas City played the
first week but I don't hear this [ __ ]
[ __ ] about us gonna be you know oh my
god you guys are without a doubt the
number one seed you guys gonna go
undefeated all this dumb [ __ ] I'm
already hearing actually from you know a
lot of other Patriots fans it's like
you're not [ __ ] watching the Kansas
City Chiefs so and I'm sure they're not
happy about that loss last year and
they're gonna come gunning for us so we
will see what happens
Antonio Brown we got to see what happens
with the case was it [ __ ] is he
getting blackmailed did he do it who
knows you know who knows everybody on
Twitter either innocent or guilty seems
to know without seeing any evidence they
do their own [ __ ] research through I
don't know other people's Instagram
videos and then all of a sudden they we
reached a verdict your honor it's like
yeah we haven't even started the
preliminaries so we shall see the giant
stink the giant stink I gotta be honest
truth here's something I called I told
[ __ ] Birds he from day one getting rid
of Tom Coughlin's was the stupidest
[ __ ] thing this [ __ ] thing where
it's just like you know we needed to
change your scenery not a changes for
you wouldn't say we needed to change the
culture whatever the [ __ ] they say I
mean the Giants you know stuck when I
was a really little kid but ever since
I've been a teenager I'm now 51 has been
a quality franchise and made great
decisions this is the biggest bonehead
move that they [ __ ] made Tom Coughlin
undefeated against Bill Belichick who
owns everybody else
in Super Bowls [ __ ] owns everybody
else alright and I know I'm gonna hear
some [ __ ] Eagle fans because they had
one good goddamn day I wouldn't take
that away from you but if you really
want to put your coach up against our
coach any day of the [ __ ] week
alright but Tom Coughlin's they did it
twice and the second that guy [ __ ]
left he made the Jaguars a good team
goes to the [ __ ] Giants they get to
[ __ ] rings now he's back with the
Jaguars and the Jaguars are immediately
a [ __ ] team that you have to [ __ ]
reckon with makes no goddamn sense to me
that you would get rid of that guy so
good on Jacksonville to get the guy back
he's 1 everywhere Boston College
Jacksonville New York Giants and
Jacksonville again guys like that do not
come around me talk to that guy he's a
hall-of-famer and I don't know what they
thought they did I don't know if they
thought the game passed him by he had
too much white hair I have no [ __ ]
idea
stupid [ __ ] move and then last thing
last thing that I want to talk about
football [ __ ] Sunday other than the
Rams handling the Saints and I think
that that their coach I forget his
[ __ ] name is Theus Lee I'm not saying
anything new but that guy is the next I
think brilliant mind in coaching which I
don't know why I get so [ __ ] geeked
about coaching
I like when NFL Films stuff stuff on
players I love it but there's nothing I
like better it was when they just start
like talking about some of the great old
school coaches and then one of my
favorite football geek things is
coaching trees which is why I became a
Lions fan because I root for Matt
Patricia out there I don't what the hell
he did there was like probably body
language hoping a [ __ ] field goal
would go through the uprights and that
gave me other day tours meniscus why she
was the Chargers we've missed it all the
field goals that [ __ ] Seattle
Seahawks challenge
on a non-call of a pass interference I
didn't even know you could [ __ ] do
that
how much more advantage are you gonna
give to the often there wasn't even pass
interference and he went back and he
looked at I think oh that's right the
team with the ball had something bad
happened to him I I gotta be honest with
you man I am the [ __ ] Pittsburgh
Steelers are just snake-bitten I've
never seen a team that just in this new
[ __ ] I don't know no no helmet to
helmet hit era in the NFL I don't think
any franchise has gotten [ __ ] like
substantially like costing them the game
more than the Pittsburgh Steelers if
there's another team please let me know
I've kind of pay attention to the AFC
but I remember that that [ __ ] time we
first of all like half the defense has
gotten suspended for tackling people
there was a you know they haven't beaten
us and forever and they actually beat us
they scored a [ __ ] touchdown and then
some [ __ ] I don't know
tuck rule 2.0 thing came in and then now
actually that touchdown he just saw
wasn't a touchdown and then we ended up
winning the game and then [ __ ]
yesterday I watched them you know great
tight coverage great non-call pass
interference Pete Carroll throws his
little [ __ ] red hanky on they go by
the wheel you can't even fear that I
just like I could I can't [ __ ]
believe I get in bounds out of bounds I
get that [ __ ] but like literally chants
saying I'm throwing a flag cause I feel
like you should have I don't know when
the [ __ ] that started but uh I don't
know
Jesus Christ but I haven't said that I'm
done complaining I guess I guess I am
although that's the whole backbone of
this podcast about how bad defenses get
[ __ ] in this new Pro offense era that
we're in I don't know I'm just gonna
just forget it and just be like this is
you know the fourth quarter with three
minutes left in a lot of NFL games as is
as listen to this segue is as fun is the
last four laps of a [ __ ] MotoGP race
did anybody watch the last one from San
Marino
now if you're an American you probably
say to yourself where the [ __ ] is San
Marino is that near rozaine in Rhode
Island where exactly is that San Marino
is what's known as a sovereign state
okay sovereign state is basically that's
what basically this illuminati level
rich people but they they're through
afraid of hurricanes so they won't buy
their own island to have their [ __ ]
sex parties on so what they do is they
carve out a part of a country and
they're just like we're our own country
without an army and you guys are going
to protect us because we have this much
money but then we're not going to pay
taxes for the army I made up that last
part I don't what that part's true a
sovereign state refers to a state that
possesses full sovereignty oh thank you
in orange is a fruit that's an orange I
mean what the [ __ ] would you know at
that point full sovereignty over its
affairs
I guess freedom existence in territory
it is completely in itself a sovereign
state is recognized as being a
legitimate nation by other major nations
in the world the minor minor nations
that they're not a [ __ ] nation look
bigger than you major characteristics of
a sovereign state are super rich white
people going to Eyes Wide Shut parties
sex trafficking this is all right here
on the Wikipedia page I'm kidding
major care to a defined territory on
which the state exercises internal and
external sovereignty all right I'm going
to look at the definition of sovereignty
because this sounds like it's it's it's
beyond okay sovereignty definition all
right sovereignty power how can we hope
to Jesus Christ they give me a quote the
authority of a state to govern itself or
another state a self-governing state
supreme power or authority right there
supreme power I think it's just a bunch
of I got to look up sovereignty state
conspiracy theory I can't spell it out
of [ __ ] it's such a tricky [ __ ]
word
sov er this is one I'll never be able to
spell earn2life dit and I somehow spelt
it right all right it's not SOR it's sov
er sovereign state conspiracy what's the
deal with sovereign states with
sovereign citizens great this is going
to be perfect conspiracy theory it's
combining bad ad stand up come on man
give me a conspiracy theory here all
right FBI the sovereign citizen movement
ok FBI's freaking out about this [ __ ]
domestic terrorism Americans attacking
Americans because of us-based extremist
ideologies comes in many forms in a
post-911 world well we kind of have an
extremist [ __ ] foreign policy enough
to help educate the public we've
previously outlined two separate
domestic terror threats eco-terrorist
animal rights extremists and loan of
people who like animals are on this FBI
list stop killing rescue dogs
we need to bug that house I want to know
what these [ __ ] people are doing
these animal people I guess what are
they like blowing up fisherman boats or
something today we look at a third
threat the sovereign citizen extremist
movement sovereign citizens are an
anti-government extremists who believe
that even though they physically reside
in this country they are separate or
sovereign from the United States
yeah hippies spoiled people as a result
they believe that they don't oh actually
super rich people
so what am I talking why am i blame in
the [ __ ] non-working man man they
believe they don't have to answer to any
government Authority including courts
taxing entities motor vehicle
departments of law enforcement yeah this
sounds like the sons and daughters of
the super wealthy this causes all kinds
of problems and crimes
yeah like backing over people and then
driving home and when the [ __ ] cops
show up your lawyer meets them in the
driveway and says yeah she'll turn
herself in and the following morning you
remember that [ __ ] publicist in New
York and Long Island did that I remember
reading that as a younger man gold I
didn't know you could [ __ ] do that
for example many sovereign citizens
don't pay their taxes they hold the
legal courts that issue warrants for
judges and police officers they clog up
the court system system with frivolous
lawsuits and liens against public
officials to harass them and they use
fake money orders personal checks and
and the like at government agencies
banks and businesses well yeah that's
their protests that Bank the banking
system is nothing but a Ponzi scheme
that's just the beginning but the thing
is they need if everybody believes to
lie that I think we're good that's just
the beginning not every action taken in
the name of the sovereign citizen
ideology is a crime but the list of
illegal activities committed by these
groups cells and individuals is
extensive and puts them squarely on our
radar in addition to the above sovereign
citizens that's not well I'm reading out
loud when it's something I'm interested
in commit murder and physical assault
G's has threatened judges and law
enforcement professionals and government
personnel impersonate police officers
the diplomats are these guys are
[ __ ] use fake currency passports
license plates and driver's license say
you know you're underage you want to get
a drink engineer various white-collar
scams including mortgage fraud and
so-called redemption schemes now wait a
minute that's like super mainstream
though [ __ ] let all those people go
didn't you all right I have no idea
anyway so what did I talk MotoGP race in
the sovereign state of
these [ __ ] murderers who don't have
paid [ __ ] taxes and impersonate
police officers evidently I'm telling
you guys you got to watch it came right
down to the last [ __ ] lap the race
starts all the Suzuki's we're in first
place Fabio Quattara quarter raro
maverick viñales was he in the beginning
Alex Riggs I forget who the [ __ ] was in
the boobs all I know is a three Suzuki's
I'm still learning the sport and then
you just what - you just got to watch
Marc Marquez run all these guys down and
then he's behind Fabio quarter ro and
just became Fabio Marquez show for the
rest of the race and Marquez followed
him all the way to the last left like I
felt like 17 [ __ ] laps he was just in
second place and that's got to be
unsettling for a younger rider to have
the greatest [ __ ] writer of since I
don't I guess a Valentino Rossi as far
as my limited understanding of the sport
before you jump all over me just behind
you for 17 laps looking at all your
strengths and weaknesses and just
figuring out okay on the foot and he
just waits till the final lap and then
the final epic they past each other like
two or three [ __ ] times but I was
really impressed with the power of the
Suzuki in the end where Fabio had
another run at him but right as Marquez
braked Fabio was too closely he had to
like he had to come hard on the brakes
and then Marquez just kind of broke away
kind of [ __ ] over the excitement of
the last like two three turns but
Marquez wanted to congratulations to him
and once again another outstanding race
despite the fact it was in a sovereign
state full of murderers impersonators
and people with fake IDs you know I
don't understand why do they get
recognized how does this I this really
fascinates me it's just like say like
Monaco you're right in France you get to
be on the [ __ ] French Riviera
and but you don't have to pay any taxes
for France and you're in France
how does a sovereign state coming back
you mentioned I read up on this [ __ ] and
I figured out how to become a sovereign
state with it but then I would be [ __ ]
cuz then I'd have to trade with you guys
I'd have no food supply when I can't do
that I was a dumb idea you know and you
guys won't let me read up on this [ __ ]
eat how does it country become a country
what constitutes how does it country
become a country I gotta take bloodshed
alright what constitutes the sovereign
state why can't they just answer the
[ __ ] question
or get to it this person writes this how
they started one might try to determine
just what constitutes a sovereign state
empirically by examining the
characteristics of states whose
sovereignty is indisputable just [ __ ]
tell me I got my hat in my hand I'm
asking you can you imagine if you went
to somebody's house for a party like
excuse me where's your trash one might
determine just what constitutes a trash
can by examining the characteristics of
the structure you'd be like I'm gonna
[ __ ] wash this garbage in your face
just answer the [ __ ] question you
[ __ ] alright I no longer care maybe
that's part of their [ __ ] camouflage
they make it so goddamn difficult gives
a [ __ ] alright let's go into all the
advertising here three reads Oh max what
have you been doing Oh max everybody
problem whether you're an athlete
weekend warrior or someone who deals
with constant joint pain back pain
muscle soreness or arthritis finding a
natural remedy that instantly works
might seem non-existent dude I love this
[ __ ] I tried this [ __ ] out it's [ __ ]
amazing right on my bad shoulder and my
bad knee it was tremendous most
over-the-counter pain relievers such as
icy hot and bengay only focused on one
basic cooling effect such
menthol which temporarily takes your
mind off the pain until that pain
returns in an hour or so solution if
you're looking to get rid of the nagging
muscle and joint pain immediately while
providing long lasting recovery then you
need to try the natural breakthrough
pain relief solution solution cryofreeze
CBD developed by ohm max health this
non-prescription triple action pain
relief roll-on simply for the sweet it's
a great thing - you put it on like a
deodorant formulated to block pain
receptors reduce inflammation where it
goes to the other level because
everything else just is the block pain
receptors so then it's this false sense
of feeling well and you can actually
enter injure yourself more because you
think that you're healed this is the big
part reduces inflammation and improves
muscle and joint flexibility not saying
you don't have to keep rehabbing but if
this is a great thing to help you along
the best part is I can say this -
knowing nothing about the [ __ ] human
anatomy this 100% natural CBD powdered
remedy no I got the roll-on works and
it's works its magic within 10 minutes
of application and relief less up to
eight hours much longer than the
over-the-counter products it's super
easy to throw in your gym bag and take
on the go for emergency pain relief
simply rotus it simply roll it over
where it hurts and ice out the pain with
an arctic blast Oh max health is
offering my listeners 20% off a full
bottle of cryofreeze pain relief roll-on
plus free shipping
I'm telling us meanies bug you u-joints
up telling some classic old man [ __ ]
this discount also applies towards any
product site-wide just go to oh mac
health calm had to do a different one on
that one and enter the code bird to take
advantage of this incredible savings
that is o m ax health calm and entrecote
BER to get 20% off cryofreeze
and site-wide alright I'm actually gonna
go I'm not gonna wait for the free
samples from those guys I'm gonna go buy
some of that [ __ ]
after this podcast oh look who's back
honey honey is a free browser extension
that saves you money everywhere you shop
online nine times out of 10 shopping
online beats going to the store talk
about what you like better about online
shopping compared to in store example
avoid driving less walking no crowds of
people to wade through etc well you just
took all my [ __ ] answers
that's like Eminem an eight-mile wait he
just said all this [ __ ] that the other
guy was gonna say about him and then he
had nothing all right
online shopping if somebody's already
brought it's like yeah you I already did
this you're like the last member on the
family feud and everybody did all the
obvious answers and now you got to
[ __ ] come up with one avoid driving
less walking no crowds of people to wade
through online I like the way my fingers
feel on the keyboard hey you like the
way you feel like a boy show me eight
nine times out of ten you're overpaying
when you shop online unless you use
honey describe how high in your own
words describe what honey is in your own
words well it's this amazing [ __ ] that
comes out of a tree and bears go wild
for it wait a minute honey is a free
browser extension that saves you money
everywhere you shop online
honey finds coupon codes and other
discounts across the web and applies
them automatically I don't know how it
works but honey saves me money where I
already shop it it might be magic I do
know how it works I do know how it works
and then I know how they make money
just think about how much money you
could be saving if you use honey it's
free to use install on your computer and
just two clicks and it'll save you money
so you can treat yourself to something
Knight get get honey for free at join
honeycomb / bird that's join honeycomb /
bird and then obviously they seem to be
making money I would guess by sharing
that information with other people but
most people don't have a problem with
that deal what
the white key if something does what
kind of toothpaste I just bought well
then by all means use it all right me
undies everybody
boop boop boop me undies me undies
watching what the [ __ ] I buy to do to be
undies me undies no privacy if I try
thank God it can hide my junk in soft
modal pretty soon a robots gonna come
through my door and grab me by the
throat oh and expose my balls take the
picture and take the DNA DNA to a
[ __ ] ball bag Factory and make my
replacement
starting with my [ __ ] and red junk
alright me undies makes this office most
fun undies known to man whether you like
crazy fun prints crazy fun prints or opt
for classic black the undie gives you
the freedom to express yourself
comfortably I mean that's perfect right
there I mean you just go you can have
muted colors with hey my dick isn't on
show you know you know I just I'm not
trying to put my dick on display here
alright
my dick is humble it scores a [ __ ]
touchdown and just hands the ball to the
referee or if you're more colorful you
know you're a Liberace fan yeah that day
here's my balls they have everything for
you the undies has plenty of options of
those looking to update like like
Leonard probably has like just regular
[ __ ] underwear you know where who's a
flamboyant [ __ ] I don't know
tío maybe I have no idea he's not even
know League anymore bill you can join
the monthly membership build a pack
select a matching pair to match your
better half or just pick out one pair
that strikes your fancy
they're pretty laid back man so just go
ahead and do what you want different
prints /color /size me undies are made
with soft sustainable fabric new fun
prints drop every tuesday and members
get access to exclusive prints every
month guys listen up they have a new and
improved brief designed to be more
supportive no more spell out me and it
was that [ __ ] porn stars Jesus Christ
I'll [ __ ] snug
goddamn [ __ ] undies have to be me
undies that's that's for like those
elephant [ __ ] guys just [ __ ] walking
around the goddamned trunks trying to
feed itself me undies has a great
remember that [ __ ] Buddy Hackett joke
I can't remember how it went
this guy had like a dick transplant they
put a [ __ ] his dick fell off or some
[ __ ] I'm gonna paraphrase this Buddy
Hackett tells us so much better so he
puts a [ __ ] elephant trunk where his
dick was so his [ __ ] girlfriend is
loving his dick so much that she decides
to marry him he can finally go meet the
parents so he goes over there for dinner
right and I forget what the [ __ ] do they
have they have this big [ __ ] spread
you know with all this fruit and all
this [ __ ] hanging around and all this
stuff so that's just [ __ ] sitting
there everybody's eating and all of a
sudden out of nowhere the trunk comes
out of his pants grabs an entire [ __ ]
cantaloupe and goes back underneath you
know I should have said a [ __ ] trunk
full of food and goes underneath I just
[ __ ] up the punchline by saying the
[ __ ] word the punchline whatever he
grabs a whole bunch of [ __ ] food off
the fruit belt platter and the trunk
disappears under the table of course
everybody stops their jaws on the ground
and his chick's mother goes do you mind
doing that again
the guy goes you know I'd love to but I
don't think I could fit any more fruit
at my ass I'm sorry I'm just laughing at
how bad I [ __ ] up that joke let's get
back to the [ __ ] at me undies here
different prints colors styles my undies
are made with soft sustainable fabric
new fun prints dropped every Tuesday
then members get access to exclusive
prints every month guys listen up they
have a new and improved brief designed
to be more supportive no more spill up
why don't you guys get together with
Iron Maiden and make some [ __ ]
comfortable Eddy tee underwear I'd buy
that the undies has a great offer from
my listeners for every first-time
purchaser you get 50% off and free
shipping this is a no-brainer especially
because they have 100% satisfaction
guarantee to get your 15% off your first
pair free shipping an 100
satisfaction guarantee go to my undies
calm / / that's me undies calm / / Jesus
Christ let me get a drink of water here
Oh Billy freckles have been working out
again and I don't do the [ __ ] water
thing - well nobody drank water when I
was a kid when you [ __ ] worked out
nobody's stretched you just showed up
with your matching gray sweatpants and
[ __ ] hoodie right and those old
school guys that have the towel around
their neck tucked into the [ __ ]
hoodie alright pulling out oh wait is
that it okay that's it for the
advertising all right let's get into the
[ __ ] questions let's get into the
questions all right this is the new
thing and I got a new [ __ ] jingle
here right here we go we're gonna read
the [ __ ] questions here that's me
[Music]
all right you want a production value on
this [ __ ] podcast you got it all
right Anibal I like that you guys get to
hear the [ __ ] [ __ ] Godsmack was was it
was a drum and shannon shannon larkin
Jesus Christ what a [ __ ] beast that
guy's all right pulling out dear Billy
of Defense I agree with you about Trump
I didn't vote for him and he doesn't do
things that represent me but you're
right that he gets no support when
talking about pulling out troops it's
[ __ ] unbelievable it's unbelievable
or he's gonna talk to the Taliban even
though he to the end said I'm not
[ __ ] doing it but I mean just as long
as there's somebody trying to [ __ ] me
with just emerging cash for the love of
[ __ ] God
you heard Democrats spewing the same
things Republicans did when they were
pressed with scaling down on our
presence in the Middle East they all
vote for war and we need another party
but for now we need people to recognize
what's right even if it comes out of the
mouth of someone you don't like I'm
gonna read that last sentence again for
now we need people to recognize what's
right even if it comes out of the mouth
of someone you don't like love you love
the special thank you that's one of the
biggest [ __ ] problems that you have
with people who are politically active
it's like this sports fan and their team
can do no [ __ ] wrong and they just
want to they want to start history with
say if they're democrat they want is if
they want to talk about the banking
system they go below George Bush bah bah
bah bah bah bah and these [ __ ] people
Republicans will Obama did this and
before Obama was there during George
Bush Republicans would be like well Bill
Clinton you can thank Bill Clinton for
that he can [ __ ] thank Bill Clinton
further right and I always [ __ ] you
know liberals right now we're talking
about bad [ __ ] Donald Trump is and
you know I mean we just had a [ __ ]
Democrat in there for eight years and he
couldn't [ __ ] get us out of
you know any of this [ __ ] that we're
[ __ ] in I mean I that's a tall order
to ask one person to do but they're all
kind of like they're all getting paid by
the same [ __ ] people if you look at
the [ __ ] speech schedule of a retired
president they're all playing the same
college gigs if you know what I mean
all right you know I swear to god this
[ __ ] black moles ever since I you
know I had at any event I gotta go get
checked out
it's like I feel good but it's just this
[ __ ] [ __ ] I can't get out of my
goddamn throat open oh my because you
smoked for cigars a week it can't be
that it's got to be the toilet all right
okay pulling up dear Billy of Defense I
agree with you own eye or did that one
okay clouds hey Billy sky balls all
please by all means I hope this is
somebody who's a [ __ ] pilot or
something I'm actually really into
whether enough looking at the clouds and
not being like oh that looks like a
Dalmatian I'm actually now trying to
figure out what kind of cloud it is all
right so here we go last week I was
listening to you try to sort out the
smorgasbord of sexual terms for that
lady with the polyamorous aka cheating
ass boyfriend that stuff is all Greek to
me so I can't help you there
but if you like in the confusing terms
to the cloud types you've been
struggling to learn for your instrument
rating all right first off good on you
for doing your instrument rating even if
you never fly IFR it means instrument
flight rules for all you guys not doing
the [ __ ] I don't know [ __ ] about it this
is VFR and ifr VFR is visual flight
rules which is fortune theme starts put
so eloquently I can fly VFR I can only
fly when it's nice up when there's at
least five statute miles visibility and
you know I can see what the [ __ ] going
on
IFR is when you're in the clouds and
[ __ ] or you're above the clouds where
you can you know okay you need to land
in a city and it's completely covered in
clouds like where the [ __ ] is the
airport where the buildings where is
this [ __ ] that I'm going to run in
- and you have to have the [ __ ] balls
to trust your instruments and that's how
you navigate through it's [ __ ]
next-level [ __ ] all right but if Bruce
Dickinson can do it and [ __ ] tour the
world as a rock star I got damn it I can
find the time to learn how to do this
all right if even if you never fly IFR
the training will help you in low
visibility conditions and in the
unlikely event that you inadvertently
enter a cloud those skills will keep you
calm and prevent yourself from going ass
over teakettle into the ground yeah it's
[ __ ] nuts and I got to tell you
something I was I've been watching all
of these videos and I watched these
videos of people with VFR get into IFR
and [ __ ] you know unfortunately most
of them died and it is it [ __ ] it may
be literally like I don't know if I want
to [ __ ] do this anymore but
unfortunately in aviation
you know you usually learn by somebody
[ __ ] dying and the reason why I am
doing this if' IFR trading was because
somebody crashed a [ __ ] helicopter in
that [ __ ] basically almost diagonally
across the street for me when I was in
New York I just [ __ ] freak me the
[ __ ] out and you know so you either stay
scared your whole [ __ ] life or you
face it you learn what to do but you can
get when you get in the clouds
you totally learn you it's it's it's
it's hard to explain because I've never
been in it but just the way they
describe it it doesn't even seem
possible but you can literally be like
you know at night if you have no horizon
you can literally be in a spin and you
don't even know it you know and in the
centrifugal force have even had a drink
it's not even gonna spill it's like that
right at the carnival except your
[ __ ] spinning and you if you if you
go into a turn you get this thing called
the liens or all of a sudden being in
the turn feels like you're you had a
straight and level attitude and if you
look at your gauge you're like way I'm
not you look at your whatever the [ __ ]
it's called I got too much [ __ ] in my
head right now to try to [ __ ] think
your attitude indicator when you go to
level off you're gonna feel like that's
just your [ __ ] leaning way to the
right and you're the fluid in your ear
that tells you your balance is [ __ ]
lying too
and you have to look at your gauges and
[ __ ] ignore that is you're flying a
[ __ ] plane or a helicopter and you
can't even see anything and you have to
[ __ ] override that and just look at
your gauges this is the [ __ ] this is
the [ __ ] this is the real [ __ ] it's just
taking the [ __ ] training wheels off
it's terrifying and fascinating anyway
as far as the cloud types go it's pretty
easy to learn once you break down what
the Latin root words are reading them
all as a list makes it unnecessarily
confusing and can be hard to memorize
there are really only two types of
clouds you need to know yeah Stratus and
cumulus that's what I was kind of
feeling all right Stratus is Latin for
layer think fat flat fat think flat hazy
features list clouds and cumulus is
Latin for heap or pile think puffy
pillowy clouds what about the ones that
kind of look like a little bit of both
like it's Stratus and then all of a
sudden you'll just see one that looks
cumulus is that because it's just a
lifting force underneath there or as it
was moving it ran into a different I got
a different pressure system or more
moisture I have no [ __ ] idea
almost all cloud types are either one of
these terms or some combination of the
two yeah there's like all the offshoots
the other hint hidden in the name is the
altitude in which the cloud is for is
found yeah that's like Alto and all of
that [ __ ] right
this is noted with the prefix on the
front of the name for high level clouds
in Latin the word zero means high and
interestingly enough that's what the
comedy stores name was back when was a
supper club before was a comedy stores
called see Rose okay meaning high and I
actually had you know in Vegas they have
a casino out there called the
stratosphere and when I was getting my
private license I was joking with my
instructor saying I want to start a one
floor casino called the troposphere
even though it goes up to 60,000 feet it
would be just a [ __ ] joke totally all
VIP super [ __ ] high hand one floor
for only like the sovereign state
[ __ ] Eyes Wide Shut [ __ ] anyway is
is in front okay zero meaning high is in
front is in the front okay like
cirrocumulus cirrostratus and it's above
20,000 feet for mid-level clouds alto
meeting middle is in front for clouds
between 6000 to 20,000 and for the low
level clouds there is no prefix sheet
dude god bless you and then okay now
he's gonna talk about nimble which I
know me that's basically when it starts
raining and that's the ones that you
want to avoid it all costs nimbo cumulus
cumulonimbus I believe there is only one
other Latin word you need to know and
that's Nimbus which means you're [ __ ]
no or Nimbo which means rain that gets
thrown on the front of the back of words
depending on the cloud yeah that's weird
to me how it's a prefix and suffix once
you know these five terms you can pretty
much name any cloud with a few small
exceptions you see a thin flat
high-level cloud it's cirrostratus you
see a mid-level cloud that's puffy Alto
cumulus you see a big-ass tall puffy
rain cloud that looks like it could [ __ ]
you up
that's cumulonimbus that was a flight
instructor for a few years at the
beginning my career and breaking it down
like this helps students who are like
myself and weren't the best at
memorization yeah dude you really helped
me out thank you sorry to have education
on your podcast
I love the new special and good luck
with the rest of your training hey Eddie
I'll take any and all [ __ ] help I
could get on that thank you so much that
I'm gonna [ __ ] copy and paste that
and read that a thousand times until it
sinks into my old brain here alright cop
writing in dear Billy no booze I'm a
police officer in a major Canadian city
and I wanted to chime in about the
opioid fad
all crisis you were mentioning recently
it's a [ __ ] epidemic oh yeah Jesus
Christ these guys see this I would think
so much so many of their calls that they
respond to has something to relate to do
overdose or violence of somebody trying
to get this [ __ ] or whatever anyways and
the average person reading the death
toll in the paper sees the numbers but
not the faces I thought Dave Chappelle's
bid on it and his new special was funny
sad and accurate yeah
and ident and that right there is what
separates Dave from the rest of us is
his ability to be that [ __ ] dark and
I guess is a little inside thing on
Chappelle's Show the small part that I
had there when I saw the first cut of
the Law & Order sketch in the end when
the white dudes in prison trying not to
get raped and then Dave's character is
on the golf course the way they for him
and you know Neil first put that [ __ ]
thing together
it was so [ __ ] dark like it actually
made me feel like wow like what the [ __ ]
selfishly because as a white person I
could finally relate to the character
that was in the really bad situation I
just felt like he did that with that bit
the coldness of hey [ __ ] him
Jess say no and it's just like wow we
really did that to a whole race of
people and that was their kids their
parents and all of that and just let him
die it's just [ __ ] brutal and he
somehow got a laugh out of that anyway I
can't count the number of times I
respond to accidental overdose deaths
from fentanyl or even heroin on any
given week I'm sick of having to tell
parents that their adult son or daughter
was found dead and alone from an
overdose ya know because all those
[ __ ] druggies take off too because
they're gonna get
I don't know implicated or something
what if I die found dead alone from an
overdose behind a dumpster behind the
wheel of his shitty stolen Honda Civic
or in a [ __ ] McDonald's
bathroom it's also ruins it also ruins
little Timmy's goddamn Happy Meal
experience when they go to use the
bathroom and find this Jesus Christ so
what's the solution I don't [ __ ] know
bill I'm a street cop and the people in
charge of this [ __ ] are too entrenched
in red tape to take suggestions but I do
have to my two cents I would love the it
let seems like two of the smartest
[ __ ] back-to-back emails I ever got
you know nobody asking for advice
they're educating no faculty all right
it's true that almost all homeless
people have a mental illness and /or a
drug addiction the three are tied
together in a destructive cycle of petty
crime to feed the habit wandering around
like zombies from The Walking Dead
ending up in jail and /or eh why don't I
just say and/or why am i reading the
slash and or a hospital ers slash psych
ward visit then back on this street
without solving anything whatsoever yeah
cuz there's no money in it
because these rich constant [ __ ] give
a [ __ ] about anything and I don't know
how the politicians work in your country
but ours are set up to be bribed they're
grossly grossly [ __ ] underpaid so they
need someone to finance their [ __ ]
it's like a band trying to get signed by
a record label back in the deal and you
just get [ __ ] raped so how do we
break in this break the cycle my opinion
is forced long term rehab it sucks to
say but there are plenty of resources
out there for addicts slash homeless
people to get better but most would
rather not go through the trouble once
they are strongly addicted they need to
be taken out of the general population
for their own and others safety and the
addiction / mental illness combination
can lead to unpredictable behavior and
violence doesn't all of this makes sense
we've got money for all this other [ __ ]
why don't we do this the facilities
themselves and you know what someone
would figure out how
to give them their right [ __ ]
treatment and make money off of these
[ __ ] people the facilities themselves
need heavy independent civilian
oversight and those being held should
have regular assessment to determine
whether they can actually hold a job or
take care of themselves or whether they
- whether they're too [ __ ] from years
of drug abuse and trauma if they go they
should have regular check-ins if not try
to give purpose and meaning to their
lives and continue to have regular
assessments at the same time legalize
all drugs makes me feel weird to type
this as a cop provide them provide them
for cheap and in moderation and assess
the users for long-term rehab people are
going to use drugs whether they're legal
or not take the power away from these
[ __ ] dealers and faceless mega corpse
in China who are distributing this [ __ ]
dealing with drug use and possession as
criminal offenses has never worked and I
can tell you as a cop they are way
better using there are way better uses
of our resources well there you go man
you got anybody gonna [ __ ] argue with
that you know what somebody will some
people actually will argue with the cop
who's actually up to his eyeballs in the
[ __ ] every goddamn day about why you
can't legalize drugs all of that [ __ ]
made sense to me and if a politician
were to come along and suggest that how
much would they be [ __ ] attacked it's
unbeliev somebody comes on and actually
talks logically and says something that
makes sense that would actually cost
money but help society in general it
just it just immediately gets branded as
socialism or [ __ ] I don't know what
extreme right-wing extreme left-wing and
they just [ __ ] they just [ __ ] all over
it
and then like the same five corporations
just keep making money off of everybody
else's misery it's it's [ __ ] off I
gotta be honest with you like the
homeless situation out here in LA is
crazy and if it wasn't so goddamn
dangerous you just don't know how to
approach people I saw a woman the other
day just looked like somebody's mom and
I was thinking like maybe that was step
would be somebody that you know and it
was daylight and [ __ ]
that you could maybe try to like just
[ __ ] help out like what if I did if I
found like a family that was [ __ ]
homeless and you know I set up like a
donation thing everybody throws in a
dollar and you just [ __ ] pay for an
apartment so that you get those people
off the street
so they feel safe and they can you know
shower and get him some clothes so they
don't look like they living on the
street so the mom can go into a job
interview or something like that like I
really think at this point it's kind of
a cop-out to just sit there and [ __ ]
blame politicians because you know that
that system doesn't work in their hands
are tied I think it's kind of like it's
up to you know just regular people you
know I live in this city why don't I try
and take care of it I don't think it's
enough at this point it's not working
that I just take care of myself and if
you have a little bit of means or
something like that I don't know maybe
that could be something to look into I
just have no idea how to [ __ ]
approach somebody on the [ __ ] street
like that and I don't feel like getting
this [ __ ] kicked out of me or gets
scratched and then have to take 42
[ __ ] shots to the atom abdomen you
know those rabies shots or some [ __ ] see
look at that I'm [ __ ] up yeah I'm
nervous I would be nervous to do that
but that could be a I don't know
everybody gets there one person off the
[ __ ] street you know as opposed to
they just all these [ __ ] banks just
loaning out all these money for these
[ __ ] construction company to keep
knocking down cool [ __ ] for regular
people to do to put up another [ __ ]
unoccupied [ __ ] apartment building
they'll nobody can afford to go in -
Jesus Christ I'm on my soapbox this week
let me see here here we go one more time
time for preaching
kunti these theories from somebody else
all right where am I here let's get back
to the goddamn podcast here dad at that
all right rookie firefighter dear Billy
ball bags I like that one
listener for a while now and seriously
love you don't give a [ __ ] and say and
say it how it is
it's so rare now I say how I think it is
but I'm just joking so everybody relax
but I don't know how it is nobody knows
how it is I just got hired into a fire I
love that last copy he kind of knew how
it was I got hired onto a fire
department took a year of applying to
every [ __ ] department possible and
I'm beyond excited to get out there and
put that wet stuff on the red stuff
water on fire lol alright I thought you
being dirty there and was wondering if
you had any advice how to deal with
dicks that I that think I can't do the
job slash the normal rookie hazing you
just got to take it sweetheart and this
is yeah I can tell you what you got to
do when they [ __ ] trash you you laugh
the worst thing you can do is get upset
and show weakness because then they're
just gonna [ __ ] be on you they're
gonna be on you if they come at you with
any misogynistic [ __ ] you just [ __ ]
roll with it don't listen to these
[ __ ] fruitcakes out there going like
you should your plane to human reason to
work with you they just break in boss
even though you don't have any but you
do have balls if you becoming a
firefighter so I don't know how that
works but you do that balls they're
pulled up in yard they they turn into
ovaries I never took a health class I
have no fun I'm a dad and I don't know
how woman's [ __ ] you don't my wife
wants sex they take it at Jiffy Lube
thanks folks I'll be here all week all
right I all right
I have zero idea how to handle someone
hitting
me at work okay because normally guys
are terrified of me and I'm engaged to
an amazing man just tell him to [ __ ] off
just tell him to [ __ ] off I can't tell
them that why I can't tell me go [ __ ]
themselves cuz then I get reprimanded
for being rude to a superior officer
alright so now tell them to go [ __ ]
themselves thanks from a fellow Jinja
well you know
go [ __ ] yourself is the most
unimaginable somebody go [ __ ] themselves
any time I would just any time somebody
started hitting on you I was just really
loud oh my god are you hitting on me
again
and then look at the other guys in the
fires how many times do I gotta shut
this guy down
he's [ __ ] relentless just I would
just do i was just i would shame them i
would every time you turn him down I
would do it loud enough for other people
to hear oh my god not even if I was
[ __ ] homeless in a tent and you had
money for an apartment what I beg you I
[Music]
would I would actually have a [ __ ]
sign just have like a [ __ ] sign that
says I don't like you and as he's hit on
you just hold it up and then I would
yell do you think he's got to get the
message you just humiliate them
absolutely they'll they'll [ __ ] laugh
and then that'll be it that's that's it
that's [ __ ] it just say hey these
these [ __ ] fire engine red pubes are
the one fire you're never gonna hose
down there buddy I would just come at
them like that
just use [ __ ] humor alright you know
I don't know
I guess guys like a woman in uniform to
let me know how that works out give me
an update all right
your fellow ginger soy extra care on
that one not saying I don't care about
the other brunettes and the [ __ ] jet
black people [ __ ] hair they're not
jet black people jet black people people
with jet black hair there we go oh jeez
I almost had a controversy when you said
jet black people were you talking about
how would a liberal talk about a black
person with extra dark skin how would
they what would be the woke way of
saying that throw in a blank here what
would be the are you talking about
glorious something blonde I want the
[ __ ] they what they would say something
stupid while still being [ __ ] you
know terrified if someone like that
moved into their narrow neighborhood not
outwardly they would do it by their
actions by immediately moving out of the
neighborhood well maybe they would
handle one family but the second the
family came in the second family came
and they they would [ __ ] leave while
they reprimanded other people about
their terms
all right single mother slash underrated
dear mr. Billy bread snatcher I'm a
single mother raising this boy with no
financial aid from nobody from anybody
it's how you supposed to say that I took
advantage from a program from a program
Omaha instituted in South Carolina Obama
sorry Omaha Obama instituted in South
Carolina that led us [ __ ] go to school
for free with free child care I love
this person for having a sense of humor
about herself so now I'm now a welder
with the house in a car I bought
outright they that's [ __ ] great that
is [ __ ] great
great to hear look at that a politician
came up with that so they're not all bad
underrated youtubing [ __ ] to fix it
yourself
I bought a refurbished fridge from a
shady guy and had to take the entire
thing apart and put it back too
in order to fix a leak as well as do the
plumbing for the ice water thingy you
did how [ __ ] great did you feel about
yourself now I know everything about my
fridge same thing for my oh seven MDX
what is that a Mazda I don't want to be
exes I don't know any cars are anymore
they all look the same so I don't care
to even know yeah I look like a soccer
mom [ __ ] but thanks to youtube I can fix
cars so long as it ain't electrical well
you could probably learn how to do that
too and it's even better that you look
like a soccer mom [ __ ] because I nobody
likes to sleep or more than me a station
wagon that blows a [ __ ] BMW M series
off the line I love that that's [ __ ]
great that makes you even cooler anyways
it's a lost art in this world of call
your guy or yeah or just throw it out
and regardless of gender or financial
circumstances we should all take the
time to know the mechanics of the things
we bought Jesus Christ that [ __ ]
statement that entire email by the cop
and then that first one but for now we
need people to recognize what's right
even if it comes out of the mouths of
someone you don't like I mean come on
people I'm gonna go out on a limb here
and think for the first time and and the
difference in clouds Jesus I think this
podcast is turning the corner I think I
need a [ __ ] jingle I think somebody's
got to make me another [ __ ] jingle I
got to sing something I don't have
another melody because I can't get the
other one out of my [ __ ] head when we
actually learn things here you know what
I learned I talk way too [ __ ] long
and I got to do David Spade's new show
I'm taping that so that I think that'll
air later on tonight I believe I'll be
taping that today so did I say taping
enough time that's the podcast go [ __ ]
yourselves and I will check in on you on
Thursday